Chris Nielsen a doctor from the U.S is
tending to an injured woman on the road
one day when he gets crushed by a car he
is immediately taken to the hospital but
it's too late and Chris is declared dead
his soul comes out of his body but he
still doesn't know that his life on
Earth has come to an end later he
reaches home and finds his wife crying
he tries to ask her what happened but
strangely she doesn't respond to him
this is when it finally Dawns on Chris
that he is just a spirit now after
embracing his death the very next second
he wakes up in heaven filled with
colorful flowers glorious mountains and
kind-hearted people like him Chris is
taken aback by the beauty of the place
some days later his wife also dies and
Chris becomes somewhat happy believing
that they will reunite however she
actually ends up in hell for something
wrong she did in her life desperate to
bring back his beloved wife Chris takes
help from the wisest person in heaven
and travels all the way to Hell on
reaching there he finds why the place is
actually called hell filled with burning
shipwrecks Souls with their bodies
trapped inside the grounds and gloomy
rooms where not even an ounce of
happiness is present Chris is left with
shivers down his spine now he only has
three minutes to find his wife or else
he will be trapped in the desolate Place
forever following this we are taken a
few decades in the past where Chris is
still alive one day during a holiday in
Switzerland he meets an artist named
Annie Collins when their boats
accidentally bump into each other the
two quickly hit it off and this
encounter eventually turns into a
marriage the couple go on to have two
children Ian and Marie and the entire
family lives a happy and Beautiful Life
the movie then fast forwards to 17 years
in the future the family is close as
ever and their bond is unbreakable one
day all of them can be seen playing in
the garden with no signs of depression
or anxiety however as they say all good
things must come to an end on a fateful
day when the children depart for college
they meet with a terrible accident and
pass away four more years pass by and
Chris and his wife have finally come to
terms with their loss unfortunately God
has other plans for the family and one
day Chris Witnesses a crash inside a
tunnel several cars Collide into one
another leaving many people dead and
some seriously injured being a doctor
Chris cannot see the people suffer so he
rushes to help a woman who has been
stuck upside down in her car
unfortunately as he is trying to help
another car comes flying in and collides
into him after Chris's Soul leaves his
body an unknown voice speaks to him and
keeps him company Chris believes that
the voice belongs to the doctor who is
treating him but in reality he has
already been declared dead at the
hospital he then visits his house where
his dogs notice him and start barking
however the same cannot be said for his
widowed wife Annie and the other morning
people meanwhile the invisible person
informs Chris that he died but the
latter refuses to believe it to prove
that he's not lying the man partially
reveals himself and mentions that he can
only be seen in full when Chris finally
accepts his death after a while Chris
starts going through his family photos
this reminds him of the time when their
dog Katie contracted a terminal illness
and they had to put her down I hope this
movie gets happier soon Marie was
completely against it and the family had
a hard time convincing her that they
simply wanted to put Katie out of her
misery Chris also remembers the time he
and Ian went on a jog inside a forest
there he broke the news to son that they
were transferring him to a new school
the scene then cuts to Chris's funeral
where he finally starts coming to terms
with the fact that he has died at the
church he again attempts to speak to her
but fails however Annie feels a strange
sensation when he is close to her later
at home Chris notices the painting Annie
had made for their marriage anniversary
which is the same day Chris died the
painting depicts a mountainous landscape
where the two were planning to live
after retirement in their bedroom Chris
watches Annie writing a journal to cope
with his death but it is not doing
anything to hop a grief stricken Annie
Chris pities her and decides to let her
know that he is still with her he grabs
her hand and steers it with a pen making
her write a message on the paper saying
this is Chris I still exist however
instead of feeling comforted and he
panics and she suffers from an anxiety
attack one day a depressed Annie goes to
the cemetery to visit her late husband's
grave seeing her hurting Chris Embraces
her from behind but it only makes her
break into tears and he feels like she
is going insane because she keeps
imagining things that can't be real as a
result Chris finally realizes that his
presence will cause any more pain so he
decides to move on the very next second
he wakes up in a heaven that he has
created with his imagination the
surroundings are a mountainous landscape
that resembles a painting created by his
wife and is similar to a place where the
two desired to spend their old age a
young and healthy Katie is also part of
his idea of Heaven just then the
invisible voice finally assumes a proper
form and it is revealed to be Morgan
Freeman or I mean the younger version of
Albert Lewis Chris's former Mentor who
passed away at the age of 66. Chris is
happy to see him and the latter guides
him on how to use his mind to control
his surroundings it turns out Chris can
make alterations to his surroundings
using his mind Albert then takes him to
their residence and he drew in her
painting there he shows him a trick he
makes a hole in the wall creating a
beautiful and realistic world at the
same time Annie starts painting to cheer
herself up lo and behold the tree she
draws also appears in Chris's Heaven A
young Annie also appears near the tree
so he tries to rush to her but by the
time he reaches the tree Annie
disappears this confuses even Albert
because the presence of a living person
in heaven is very unusual he then
hypothesizes that any appeared because
she and Chris have a very strong
connection a connection that even death
cannot separate and now that you are
trying to reconcile again unfortunately
in the real world Annie destroys her
painting when she realizes that it won't
bring her husband back as a result the
tree in heaven also dries up and all the
leaves wither away later Chris finds his
daughter's soft toy oh that's sweet it
reminds him of the time she got sick oh
and he had to stay home and teach her
chess it suddenly Dawns on Chris that if
he's found his dog Katie he should also
be able to see his children Chris then
falls asleep and when he wakes up he
finds Albert gone however a beautiful
woman named Leona approaches him and
reveals that Albert is assigned her to
keep him company while he's gone to
guide other Souls Leona was an air
hostess that once served Chris and his
daughter Marie on a flight meanwhile on
Earth Annie begins to feel guilty for
Chris's death as he was out running
errands for her when he got killed it's
then revealed that Annie also blames
herself for her children's death she
feels that if she had been driving them
around they wouldn't have lost their
lives back in heaven Leona takes Chris
to a city filled with Souls enjoying
them there they watched some Souls
reincarnating before they go on a boat
ride Chris slowly begins to realize that
the city looks similar to the miniature
Marie had in her room Leona then reveals
that she didn't look like this when she
was alive and that she adopted the looks
of a woman she admired she chose to look
like the flight attendant because when
she was young her father had
complimented that woman hearing this
Chris finally realizes that Leona is
actually his daughter Marie this creates
an emotional reunion between the two and
they Rejoice with a warm hug on Earth
and he is struggling to move on her
therapist is trying to send her to a
clinic because he's afraid she may try
to harm herself like she apparently did
in the past unfortunately she does just
that and commits the unthinkable later
Albert pays Chris a visit and brings him
the bad news Chris is heartbroken but
he's also relieved that Annie's
suffering is finally over and hopefully
they will reunite soon however Albert
reveals that she will go to hell because
that's where people who commit the
unthinkable go Annie has broken the laws
of life and now she will have to pay for
it this breaks Chris's heart and his
Heaven Is eclipsed by dark clouds but he
still refuses to to let his wife go
hence without thinking twice Chris
decides to venture into hell and rescue
the love of his life Albert warns him
about its consequences but Chris is
unfazed he is adamant on reuniting with
Annie one way or another seeing his
passion and determination Albert
eventually gives in and takes him to the
tracker the only person who can help him
navigate through hell the tracker agrees
to help but he warns Chris that even if
they find Annie it will be of no use as
she has already lost all her memories
Chris still insists on trying so he
Albert and the tracker begin their
Voyage on a boat across the seas of Hell
after hours of traveling suddenly a wild
storm shakes the boat and the lost souls
in the water gang up on them the boat
immediately capsizes and as the group
tries to stay afloat Chris has a
flashback of him and Annie arguing about
their son's future it turns out Chris
was putting a lot of pressure on his son
to do well in college and it was taking
a toll on Ian eventually the sea waves
sweep the group to the shores of the
gateway to Hell surprisingly the place
is dark and gloomy filled with
shipwrecks and burning fires the trio
continues their search for any but they
are unable to locate her because Chris
is still being haunted by the memory of
his son Ian the movie then flashes to
the forest where Chris had gone for a
jog with his son Ian explains to his dad
that he is not academically gifted like
him and school is difficult for him
however being the great dad that he is
Chris Comforts him saying that he
believes in him he also adds that if he
has to go through hell he would want
nobody else but his son by his side
relevant but still a weird thing to say
the scene then flashes back to Ian's
funeral where Chris gave a speech in
which he described the man Ian would
have grown up to become had he been
given the chance Brave thoughtful loyal
back in the present Chris watches Albert
preparing to fight a group of lost souls
with this he realizes that Albert is
actually Ian and the father-son duo
Embraces each other in yet another
emotional encounter Chris is happy to
reunite with Ian but the tracker tells
him that he can't find Annie with his
son because he's a distraction Chris
refuses to leave his son behind but Ian
tells him to go he also admits that he
adopted Albert's appearance because he's
the only person Chris ever listened to
before parting ways he tells his dad to
take care of his mom just like he did
after both his children died later as
the tracker and Chris take an elevator
to Hell the latter begins to think about
all the things he had mentioned it's
then revealed that after Ian and Marie's
death Annie tried to commit the
unthinkable and she was admitted to a
mental hospital during this time the
couple's marriage hit an all-time low so
Annie demanded a divorce back in the
present Chris and the tracker eventually
reached their destination where the
floor is filled with creepy faces
calling out for their loved ones after a
bit of looking around Chris finally
locates his wife's face he runs up to
her but ends up falling through a hole
in the floor and into a lake however he
manages to swim out and it discovers the
place that she's at it's a dark and
nightmarish version of their dream house
the tracker explains that the house is a
representation of the guilt and he
inflicts on herself he also reveals that
he is the real Albert and warns Chris
that if he stays with Annie for more
than a few minutes he may be permanently
trapped in hell now the best he can do
is Bid a final farewell to his wife
after the tracker leaves the room Chris
walks up to Annie but as expected she
doesn't recognize him therefore he
pretends to be a neighbor that admires
her art and he welcomes him and
expresses her concern for her missing
paintings taking this as the perfect
opportunity Chris starts consoling her
and even tries to distract her with an
incident from his life in the flashback
Chris visits Annie at the mental
hospital the doctors have failed to
rehabilitate Annie so Chris tells her
that he has finally decided to stop
trying to force her to be normal he says
that even though it pains him a lot to
see her like this he wants to let her be
for as long as she is happy however his
Chris proceeds to leave and he stops him
and mentions that she wants to go back
to her normal life back to the present
Annie thinks it's a touching story but
doesn't react much she then expresses
her interest in seeing her family again
unaware that her husband is right there
in front of her hearing this Chris
immediately makes Annie close her eyes
and asks her to remember the day of her
marriage surprisingly Chris appears in
her memory but when she opens her eyes
and sees him she freaks out and refuses
to believe that he is her husband with
this Chris realizes that no matter what
he does he will never be able to get his
wife back hence he decides to tell her a
few ultimate words before leaving he
apologizes for all the things he'll
never give her and all the times he'd
failed her he also thanks her for
everything she's done for him and he
tears up as Chris leaves but it turns
out that he actually decided to stay
with her in hell he walks up to Albert
and instructs him to return alone saying
that heaven is where his wife is he also
requests Albert to take care of his
children following this Chris re-enters
the house and expresses his love for
Annie saying he'll stay in eternity in
hell if that's what it takes for her to
regain her sanity these words from Chris
parallel something that he said to Annie
at the mental hospital and because of
this she regains her memories however
it's too late for Chris as he has
already stayed in hell for too long he
has now become a part of it surprisingly
when Chris opens his eyes he finds
himself in heaven once again it turns
out that he was too pure and good for
hell that's why they rejected him and
sent him back to Heaven even Annie is
present there and also the kids the
movie ends with a toy boat of a small
boy accidentally bumping against the one
belonging to a small girl much like how
Chris and Annie met in Switzerland
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching